so wenigstens eins macht einem jahr
gerade hoffnung noch noch können die
populisten von dieser krise nicht
profitieren grenzschließung werden doch
eigentlich der feuchte traum der fdp
mann ist schließlich ein virus mit
migrationshintergrund
tatsächlich haben aber selbst afd
politiker offenbar skrupel corona zu
instrumentalisieren
also bis auf jörg merten der twitter
zitat jetzt kommt merkels
wirtschaftskrise und sie wird brutal ja
eine weltweite pandemie ausgelöst von
angela merkel persönlich natürlich oder
wer schuld eine welt die so vernetzt ist
das eine immobilienblase in den usa mich
meinen job in deutschland in der
auto-branche kosten kann
in der mich ein virus zu hause in
heinsberg in quarantäne bringt der sich
nehmen sich an arbeiter aus der
chinesischen provinz zwei monate zuvor
vielleicht bei einer mittagspause beim
verzehr einer fledermaus super
angefangen hat fledermaus suppe jetzt
mit ganzen fledermäusen
es ist insgesamt eine schwierige zeit
für die afd
denn der verfassungsschutz hat ja wissen
sie bernd löcke und sein flügel gerade
offiziell zum beobachtungs fall erklärt
ja der flügel wird beobachtet und als
der behördenchef diese entscheidung
verkündet hat wirkt er ja geradezu
beschwingt es ist tatsache dass ein
signifikanter bedeutungszuwachs der
maßgeblichen träger der extremistischen
bestrebungen im flügel nahm sich die
protagonisten björn höckel und andreas
kalbitz gegeben ist
beide personen sind rechtsextremisten
sind rechtsextremisten vielen dank
captain obvious heute hat sich der afw
vorstand so flügel krisensitzung
getroffen der vorstand das kam dabei
raus wünscht sich jetzt dass der flügel
sich bis ende april freiwillig selbst
auflöst toi toi toi
tatsache ist aber nach schätzungen genau
weiß man das nicht gehören bis zu ein
drittel der mitglieder dem flügel an
er ist sehr sehr mächtig der flügel
immer noch da droht jetzt vielleicht
eine parteispaltung und was der bernd
für seine kritiker in der partei plant
das hat er ja gerade erst im kleinsten
kreis verraten
das wichtigste zu leben was wir zu
erwarten haben nämlich die einheit
wieder ein wenig auch noch
ausgeschlossen
[Musik]
ja die muss man gnadenlos zitat aus
schwitzen ganz normales verb also
jedenfalls für einen faschisten übrigens
selbst wenn man den sogenannten flügel
jetzt beobachtet der markt für eine
völkische und rassistische partei bleibt
ja trotzdem da es gibt
nachgewiesenermaßen genug menschen die
afd wählen weil sie unsere liberale
demokratie weg haben wollen so wie herr
cohen kalbitz verwesungsgeruch einer
absterbenden demokratie war deutschland
wir sind die götterdämmerung dieses
globalisierten multikulturalismus wir
sind die totengräber der fauligen reste
dieser 68er setzung ii und riecht es
förmlich ja bei denen haben alle
metaphern immer mit faulig und verwesung
zu tun vielleicht doch meine therapie
gehen oder weniger trinken
so soll das zurück ja wir haben es
nämlich im vollsuff im taxi vergessen
passiert passiert trotzdem bleibe ich
dabei politische bildung hilft
langfristig mehr als beobachten oder gar
verbieten politische auseinandersetzung
hilft ja nix bei seinen hardcore fans
wird der hocke doch gefeiert
für die beobachtung durch den
verfassungsschutz
das tönende heute schau präsentiert
große ehre für den größten bernd aller
zeiten den größer sein flügel trägt
jetzt das höchste gütesiegel dass die
von alliierten besetzten deutschland
gmbh zu vergeben hat der flügel ab
sofort offiziell rechtsextrem und
demokratiefeindlich mehr geht nicht
einige demokratie war gestern dank
general vögel mascher kallwitz und ober
flügel für werke komponiert die guten
alten zeiten wieder vor zehn jahren
konnte ich nachts als frau allein von
der disco nach hause gehen
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mimen ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
scheiß und liegt - wollt dann abonniert
jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist ein minimal hersteller
[Musik]